Google cloud launcher offers ready-to-go
developments tax solutions and services
to accelerate development it provides an
easy and fast way to get up and running
on Google cloud platform with common
databases operating systems and web
frameworks so you spend less time
installing and more time developing in
this quick lab you'll learn how google
cloud launcher lets you quickly deploy
functional software packages that run on
the Google cloud platform even if you're
unfamiliar with services like compute
engine or cloud storage you can easily
start up a familiar software package
without having to manually configure the
software virtual machine instances
storage or network settings in this lab
quick laps will provide all the
resources you need to launch a common
web stack with cloud launcher and verify
your deployment you'll be deploying an
engine X stack but after taking this lab
you'll be able to apply what you've
learned in your own applications on the
cloud launcher website you can browse
what software you can begin working with
right away this is the for flag in the
GCP essentials quest a quest is a series
of related lab staff formal learning
paths completing this quest earns you
this badge to recognize your achievement
next up learn how to create a persistent
disk